these are essentials and I think that
you need you need something to boil
water in you need something to cook like
a steak you need something to cook eggs
you need something to season you need
something to store food we need a
cutting board and you need something to
cut with you need a couple more things
but this is really the gist of what you
need in the kitchen this is something
that you desire to cook in because it's
a great conductor of heat it cooks
beautifully I think for me there's a
this is the goal where my entire kitchen
is decked out and copper and there's a
certain level of being a total douchebag
when everything is covered if you're not
like in a French countryside or Alondra
cost but like this is just real nice
this is like five bucks six bucks if you
lose this you can replace this I
certainly have a really nice paring
knife but I tend to always use this
because it's easily replaceable it's
something used all the time
basically any serrated knife that's
cheap with a rubber handle is important
you can't really sharpen this so it's
sort of a disposable thing after a
certain point you're gonna just have to
throw this away
Oracle it becomes a back scratcher you
know it's like but for home use it's
really important I do feel that every
kitchen needs a cast-iron skillet that
are all cheap and they're all
indestructible the reality is like this
is great for baking too there's a lot of
things you can do with this but I love
cooking meat in this cast-iron skillet
you want pans that you can put in the
other plastic handle stuff no bueno
right so this is something for sure that
if you take care of will last
generations upon generation if I go to
someone's home I'm almost always going
to judge you on your kitchen and one of
the things I'm going to judge you right
off the bat is what kind of cutting
board do you use if you have one of
those thin plastic things like no like
that's not what you want to do you want
something that's dirty and something you
can do work on something that you may
not be familiar with in Japanese this is
called a Dena Bay you see this in
Chinese and Korean cooking as well this
is what I like to call one pot cook and
this is the epitome of what I like the
good thing is is it's great for phrases
you can pop in the oven can steam fish
you
full cookware is probably the most
important thing what I'm most excited
about this pan is that it's an all clad
this is one of the very few things that
America produces that is like
best-in-class
I really really believe that I feel like
one of those Hair Club for Men guys it's
like not only do I like sponsor this
like I use it myself
they're just workhorse they're fantastic
you know you don't even have to treat it
well you just clean it it'll last you
your entire lifetime pre-ground black
pepper is an abomination listen like the
only time you should use it is if you're
like you've rented a ski house or a
beach house and like it's the only thing
that's in the cupboard but fresh ground
black pepper is a necessity I'm probably
the least stylish guy that Gigi's ever
had working as some kind of
correspondent ever but I would feel like
I have some kind of sensibility and I
culinarian buy something like this this
is a lake restate pot this is a great
thing the lectures they set they're not
cheap by any means but you'd be
surprised that these are the same kind
of pots that many top chefs use they're
fantastic they're heavy they're great
for braises it's a great like just
finishing pot you can serve your food in
here and looks great if you order food
inevitably your foods going to come in
here there's no reason to buy Tupperware
there's no reason to buy those Ziploc
things this is just simply solely more
useful to use as a storage of food
your delivery container there's no
reason to throw this out if you're
furnishing your kitchen these are the
basic things that I think you need to
start off
[Music]